Speaker 1: All right, let's start with some
big but expected news, so I don't have that
much more to say about it than I've already said,
because this is exactly what we've been expecting.
Joe Biden's voting rights bill seems to be
dead because Democrats have been unable to
change the filibuster, which very clearly became
a prerequisite to really be able to do the voting
rights bill. And this is exactly what we expected.
So I don't know how much there is to say. But as
the Associated Press is reporting, voting bill
collapses, Democrats unable to change filibuster
voting legislation that Democrats and civil rights
leaders say is vital to protecting democracy.
That's true. It is collapsed when two senators
refused to join their own party in changing
Senate rules to overcome a Republican filibuster
after a raw, emotional debate. Who are those two
senators? Well, I'm sure many of you know
they are. Democratic Senator Joe Manchin
and Democratic Senator Kirsten Cinema. The outcome
Wednesday night says the app was a stinging defeat
for President Biden and his party, coming at the
tumultuous close to his first year in office,
almost to the day, Biden said in a statement after
the vote. I am profoundly disappointed, but that
he is not deterred and vowed to quote, explore
every measure and use every tool at our disposal
to stand up for democracy. So the question now is
what can be done via executive order to maybe put
in place some elements of what would have been in
the voting rights bill. But Manchin in cinema's
positions on this? Not a surprise, and the idea of
changing the filibuster, remember, was to reduce
the threshold for debating the voting rights bill
from 60. When you have 50 Democrats and you need
60 votes. You need 10 Republicans. This is pretty
simple math. The idea of changing the filibuster
was the chance to change the requirement of 60.
In order to do that, they needed all 50 Democrats.
They didn't have them. The filibuster doesn't
change, and thus there is at this time,
no path forward for the voting rights legislation.
Now, I think it's important that, you know, when
we talked about leading into the 2016 election,
there were these people who who should be really
crawling into a hole and never being heard from
again in terms of their opinions who were saying,
Hillary Trump, it's not really going to make a
difference. It's all. It's all kind of the same.
If it's not a real progressive, I don't want
the person doesn't really matter. And we said,
Well, but sir, ma'am, what about the Supreme
Court? What about all these different things?
Look at the Supreme Court at this point in time.
Look at all the thing. Look at the disasters that
ended up happening under Donald Trump. So we've
got to remember that at the same time, we have to
remember now that this is a fundamental building
block of our democracy. Republicans have made it
clear they've abandoned policy. They've abandoned
convincing people that their ideas are good.
They merely want to win on obstructing
Democrats and using voter suppression
and various other tactics to make it more
difficult to vote, to try to win elections. And
then if you don't win, try to steal the election,
that's what they do now. And so when something
like this gets stalled in its tracks, hopefully
Joe Biden can do some of this via executive order.
We don't yet know. We have to see. But remember
these kind of turning points. And one of those was
Hillary Trump. How bad could Trump really be?
Let's send a message. Let's shake it up. Wow,
what a disastrous four years. We've got to
be thinking along those same lines here.